SPEAKER: Let me give you one other example.
There is a brother-in-law-- this is a real case--
and he learns-- this is a long time ago, a couple of hundred years ago--
he learns that his sister's brother has died.
This is down in Alabama.
And there she is, living in not too good circumstances, in a not very nice area,
with her two children.
So he's feeling kind of generous and he says, you know,
I have an extra house on my farm.
If you sell the dump you're living in and move here,
I'll let you have this house for free, because I feel bad about you
living in those circumstances.
So she sells the house, she sells it at a loss,
she pulls up stakes, spends a certain amount of money moving,
and moves into this house that her brother-in-law has set aside
for her and her children.
But I told you it's a sad story.
After a year or so, the brother-in-law is not feeling so generous anymore,
and maybe he figures he doesn't like this woman all that much.
The kids, he doesn't like having them nearby at all,
so he makes them move out of this house, which belongs to him,
and move into something much less desirable.
And then, after a little while later, he throws them out of that, too.
Can the sister-in-law sue?